i wonder when aoc is going to go down to
the border and start crying like she did
under trump you remember that
the kids in cages she wasn't actually
crying in front of kids in cages she was
crying in front of a parking lot and
that white suit and she pretended to cry
and it was not
not exactly a marlon brando kind of
performance but it got the message
across
aoc
has not done that she's not going to do
that because now it's the biden
administration
which is enforcing this sort of stuff so
it's not good pr
she has been crying though
she's crying because
she was not able to stop the congress
from
giving a billion dollars to israel to
fund their their uh missile defense
system
and she so she just starts crying you
can see video of her on on the floor of
the house just sobbing oh no the jews
are gonna be able to protect themselves
no
this is defensive missiles by the way
it's not offensiveness it's the iron
dome system no those jews are gonna have
defensive weaponry no now the muslim
terrorists in the palestinian
territories can't shoot at them no first
of all hysterical people should not be
in public life okay if this woman can't
keep her emotions together
while she's on the floor of the congress
she shouldn't be there she's she's a too
frivolous a person to be there it's not
got i understand she might get reelected
but it's bad it's not good for public
life
but but it's also worth pointing out why
she is crying
she's crying because we're paying for
israel's defensive missiles
a lot of conservatives don't like
foreign aid some conservatives don't
like israel i'm not making a point on
either of those things right now i am
asking you to consider why
she is crying
she's crying that israel can defend
itself because she and her ilk view
israel as an extension and really a
creation of western imperialism they
view the modern nation state of israel
as an expansion of western imperialism
in the middle east as a symbol of
western civilization which they hate
which they want to subvert that's why
they want to get rid of israel so
regardless of your views on modern
nation state of israel regardless of
your views on us giving foreign aid
willy-nilly all over the place
don't don't get confused here
the reason that that aoc hates israel is
because she hates you because she hates
this civilization that
we on the right are attempting to defend
i'm so glad you liked that clip but hold
on
i need you to go over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher wherever
you get your podcasts subscribe to the
michael knowles show mich ael canada
w-l-e-s
s-h-o-w subscribe leave a five store
review we'll see you next time
[Music]